Farscape deserves a continuation because
it was Brave it did put itself out there
it did push the boundaries far more than
safe Star Trek ever did so yeah it
deserves a continuation because it was
the Plucky Underdog but also we deserve
a continuation because let's be honest a
lot of sci-fi nowadays is quite
sanitized it isn't as imaginative it
used to be it's not as high concept as
it used to be even shows like the
foundation which I adore and it is quite
High concept is also is a little bit
sanitized is a little bit
safe and I want to see a show that
actually has The Bravery of Farscape
that doesn't have the expectations or
the demands put on it like a show like
Star Trek does that actually maybe
nobody will be watching from the higher
ups